on va continuer de parler de cette
attaque bien sûr avec alexis poulain
notre éditorialiste alexis poulain merci
à vous êtes avec nous depuis le début de
l'après midi on a entendu ses tweets de
personnalités politiques à l'instant des
personnalités politiques bien sûr
solidaire avec les victimes
c'est quelque chose de plutôt habituel 1
en termes de communication politique oui
c'est habituel et c'est normal que les
politiques soient mobilisés devant cette
attaque qui rappelle bien entendu des
souvenirs atroces
compte tenu de la localisation de
l'attaqué au couteau et d'apporter bien
entendu leur soutien aux victimes
familles des victimes et également le
soutien aux policiers dans leur travail
donc tant mieux que tout le monde soit
mobilisé par rapport à cette attaque
jean castex et gérald darmanin vont
s'exprimer dans quelques secondes
on avait un représentant syndical de la
police juste avant vous qui n'attendait
pas forcément grand chose de ce discours
est ce que vous en attendez quelque
chose en particulier
pas particulièrement moi je pense que
c'est surtout à l'issue de la garde à
vue au parquet national anti terroriste
savoir ce qu'il en est des motivations
des attaquants parce que selon des
sources il se pourrait que ce soit bien
un attentat commandité et qui est il y
est tangible dans les semaines à venir
de forts risques d'autres d'autres
attaques donc c'est ça qui m'importe
surtout savoir quelles vont être les
déclarations à l'issue de la garde à vue
et maintenant la communication
gouvernementale bien sûr doit de se
mettre en place pour expliquer ce
dispositif qui a été quand même assez
rapide puisque on a arrêté les suspects
immédiatement après l attaque alors
plusieurs personnalités notamment
politiques
on parlait de terrorisme islamiste pour
l'instant ce n'a pas été confirmée par
la préfecture de police de paris
c'est quelque chose auquel il faut faire
attention à ses poulains
oui absolument c'est pour ça que
j'attends le savoir à l'issue de la
garde à vue qu'elles sont une motivation
de l'attaquant et s'il s'agit bien
effectivement d'un attentat islamique ou
non et s'il a été commanditée par les
groupes islamiques connu que ce soir al
qaïda dahesh ou d'autres pour connaître
l'ampleur du réseau si il en existe un
derrière les assaillants aujourd'hui ce
qui est quand même assez troublant
aujourd'hui c'est de voir la rapidité
avec laquelle sur les réseaux sociaux on
va retrouver le nom la date de naissance
les visages des assaillants ce qui sans
doute va compliquer le travail des
enquêteurs et des forces de police
c'est pas forcément la meilleure façon
de procéder dans le cadre des enquêtes
antiterroristes
vous vous parler des difficultés 1 2 de
la police autour de cette enquête la
difficulté ça va être aussi en fonction
du mode opératoire un qui change par
rapport aux aux attaques qu'on avait
connue
janvier 2015 et en novembre 2015 cette
fois cette attaque semble un peu plus un
peu moins organisés en tout cas will
attaque au couteau c'est c'est souvent
une attaque extrêmement difficile à
prévoir puisque elle peut avoir lieu
n'importe où est l'armée extrêmement
faciles à se procurer
pour l'attaquant donc ce mode opératoire
a été privilégiée ces dernières années
par des groupes islamiques
parce que ça permet de brouiller les
pistes ça permet aussi d'éviter toute la
logistique autour d' attaque que de plus
grande ampleur ce soit alarmes
automatiques ou à la bombe
donc voiture bélier couteau marteau
armes blanches en général voilà voilà ce
qui a été privilégié ces dernières
années et qui continue et qui rend
effectivement le travail de veille des
services de renseignement plus compliqué
parce que même s'il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'individus qui sont suivi un
compte tenu de leurs activités auprès
des réseaux terroristes cela ceux qui
passent à l'action parfois non pas
spécialement d'antécédents mais
n'apparaissent pas sur les radars avant
et décide soudainement assez rapidement
de d'attaqué avec ce qu'ils ont sous la
barre dont voilà un peu la nouvelle
nouveaux visages potentiellement du
terrorisme aujourd'hui année encore une
fois avec ce n'est pas qu'ils vont me
disait ensemble à l'instant il ya un
côté rassurant le fait que les groupes
terroristes ne puissent plus aujourd'hui
s'organiser pour commettre des attaques
comme celles qu'on l'a connu en janvier
et en novembre 2015
mais à côté moins rassurant de voir des
attaques comme celle d'aujourd'hui
avoir lieu oui alors les attaques comme
celle d'aujourd'hui ne veulent pas dire
que les groupes terroristes n'arrive
plus à s'organiser peut-être qu'ils
mettent davantage de temps peut-être
qu'ils utilisent d'autres d'autres
réseaux et puis il opère aussi dans
d'autres pays que la france donc
malheureusement l'activité terroriste
est toujours extrêmement haute et notre
niveau d' alerte est toujours
extrêmement haut il n'a pas baissé
depuis 2015 on a tendance un peu à
l'oublier à penser que ce temps là des
attaques étaient derrière nous ce n'est
pas le cas le virus a pris toute la
place dans l'actualité
mais bien entendu auprès des services le
niveau d'alerté reste extrêmement élevé
donc ça n'a pas changé et l'équipe ou
linge mais je me permets de vous vous
interromps puisque anne hidalgo jean
castex et gérald darmanin sont arrivés
du côté de la rue nicholas perron on les
écoute tout de suite
la compagnie de
[Musique]
maire de paris
avait en fin de matinée
rares ont été commis
dont s'est saisi le parquet
antiterroriste et monsieur le procureur
s'exprimera dans quelques instants
devant vous pour vous parler des faits
de la qualification qu'ils encourent
ce qui veut quoi en faire
j'ai d'abord voulu témoigner ma
solidarité
elle appelle les familles des victimes
et également tous les collègues de
travail de ces deux journalistes
les services de sécurité et de secours
auquel je rends hommage sont intervenus
très rapidement pour exercer leur
travail dans ces circonstances celle ci
surviennent
dans un lieu symbolique et au moment
même où se déroule le procès les auteurs
des actes indignes contre charlie hebdo
est l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
la république aura pas de rappeler son
attachement indéfectible à la liberté de
la presse sa volonté résolue par tous
les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme
et d'affirmer à la nation notre pleine
mobilisation
l'insulté
[Musique]
le parquet antiterroriste s'est saisi
aujourd'hui vous faites pour x raisons
d'abord localisation de ceux ci
précisément peu vol
auparavant installée la rédaction de
charlie
deuxièmement mais gare au moment de
réalisation de thé fait c'est à dire au
moment du procès des auteurs des
attentats de janvier 2015 et enfin
compte tenu de la matérialisation des
faits cet ingénieur de la volonté
manifeste de l'auteur d'attenter à la
vie de deux personnes dont il ignorait
tout et qui se trouvaient à ce moment là
simplement on pose le cigare nous avons
décidé de ne saisir du chef de tentative
d'assassinât en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
ainsi que pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes crime de nature
crise
ces îles sont de l'anc est proprement
dit l'auteur principal a été arrêté
actuellement en garde à vue un deuxième
individu est également s en garde à vue
afin de posséder un sens de vérification
s'agissant de ses relations avec
l'auteur principal dont je viens de
parler
l'enquète va donc se poursuivre elle a
été confiée à la direction régionale de
la police judiciaire de paris est ainsi
que alain direction générale de la cie
bloqués à l'intérieur la vie chère
j'aurais certainement l'occasion dans
les prochains jours de fournir d'autres
éléments qui nous permettront de faire
le point sur l'évolution des
investigations
je vaux mieux quand il est temps que
c'est bon de le rappeler une quel état
se trouvent les victimes
ne sont pas en danger
[Musique]
quand voilà pour cette déclaration vous
lui avez vu à l'écran
jean castex accompagné de l inalco
gérald darmanin et puis jean françois
ricard le procureur de la république
anti terroriste jean françois ricard qui
a rappelé bien entendu les informations
de cette attaque à l'armé blanche ce
matin dans les rues du à 11e
arrondissement de paris jean françois
ricard qui a rappelé que les deux
suspects avaient été arrêtés et qu'ils
étaient actuellement a placé en garde à
vue et que l' enquête avait été confiée
vous l'avez entendu également au parquet
anti terroriste nous sommes toujours en
compagnie d'alexis poulain notre
éditorialiste merci une nouvelle fois
alexis poulain d'être resté avec nous
sur arte france qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir de cette intervention de jeu de
jean castex du procureur de la
république antiterroriste bien c'est
surtout les informations du procureur
qui sont important de savoir qu'il y a
deux suspects aujourd'hui en garde à vue
et que l'enquêté confiée à la direction
en général la sécurité intérieure pour
connaître les motivations de l'attaquant
et savoir ce qu'il en est des réseaux
derrière ou pas cette attaque est bien
entendu revendications possible ou non
par un groupe terroriste donc voilà la
fois à savoir et jean castex qui a
rappelé que heureusement les jours des
victimes n'étaient pas en danger
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé on l'a
on l'a entendu un set cette réaction
ensemble des politiques une réaction qui
intervient presque trois heures et demi
après les faits est ce que c'est une
allocution qui s'est fait attendre
ou alors est-ce que c'était normal de
prendre son temps
non c'est normal de prendre son temps
dans son dans ce genre d'affaires et
puis encore une fois l'enquêté est en
cours donc ce n'est pas nécessaire non
plus de prendre la parole de trop en
dire
compte tenu du travail des enquêteurs
donc il faut gérer la communication le
temps de la communication
dire bien sûr aux citoyens ce qu'il en
est de cette attaque et c'est ce qui a
été fait de manière assez sobre par le
premier ministre son ministre de
l'intérieur et le procureur jean castex
a affirmé qu'il était déterminé à lutter
contre contre le terrorisme
est ce qu'on peut imaginer peut-être
dans dans les jours à venir des
nouvelles mesures de nouvelles choses
justement pour lutter une nouvelle fois
contre le terrorisme alors j'espère
qu'il ne sera pas question de nouvelles
lois d'exception on a déjà suffisamment
assez non ce qu'il faut c'est bien
entendu s'assurer des moyens qui sont
données et aux enquêteurs et aux
services de renseignement et aux
services de police ce matin jean castex
était d'ailleurs assez 1 3 et à saint
denis où il y avait un renfort des
policiers dans les différents
commissariats
donc la question est celle des moyens
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la france a
suffisamment de moyens pour avoir des
services des renseignements fonctionnel
et pour prévenir de futures attaques est
ce que nous sommes équipés et ça c'est
la question en question d' arsenal
juridique je ne crois pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de continuer le débat
sécuritaire qui a déjà suffisamment eu
lieu lors des attaques de 2015 avec les
lois d'exception que nous connaissons et
qui sont toujours en vigueur entre est
maintenant dans la loi alexis poulain la
confirmation aussi de jean françois
ricard le produit le procureur de la
république antiterroriste et qui
confirme un que les deux suspects ont
bien été interpellé qu'ils sont
actuellement en garde à vue c'est une
nouvelle rassurante bien entendu un oui
c'est une nouvelle rassurante qui va
permettre aussi d'aller vite de travail
dans quête à savoir que les suspects
sont en vie ils sont en bonne santé et
vont pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions pour connaître leurs
motivations et les réseaux ou non qui
qui sont derrière cette attaque et le
pourquoi de cette attaque
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
été avec nous restez bien entendu
avec nous tout au long de cette journée
on vous retrouve merci beaucoup